checkpoint charlie seul contact entre
l'est et l'ouest entre les deux berlin
depuis le 13 août 1961 pour beaucoup
symbole de la liberté pour les guides
touristiques en tout cas une très bonne
affaire tout comme le mur de l'autre
côté aujourd'hui encore on levitte
interdiction de s'en approcher à moins
de 200 mètres de ce côté ci on visite
avant de monter sur un praticable
il y en a tous les 500 mètres pour
essayer l'espace de quelques instants de
percer les mystères de la grisaille de
l'est toujours avec angoisse
jusqu'au jour où le monde occidental
découvre un énorme chantier
en quelques mois une nouvelle capitale
sort de terre ont démoli ce qui restait
on enterre les souvenirs de 1945 on
construit de nouveaux immeubles 30
étages de nouvelles artères à la façon
occidentale hôtels ultra moderne réservé
aux touristes appartements et longues
enfilades de bureaux à l'image de la
deuxième puissance commerciale de
l'europe de l'est
un nouveau visage qui fait de berlin un
pôle d'attraction pour tous ses voisins
on y vient en vacances ou pour un week
end depuis deux ans on y trouve toujours
quelque chose d'intéressant
ce n'est pas encore la prospérité
occidentale mais par exemple dans ce
supermarché tout neuf en plein centre de
berlin est
on pourrait aussi bien se croire dans un
grand magasin de londres ou paris
petite pêche
et
mais pourtant ce n'est ni paris ni
londres
les allemands de l'est ne peuvent se
payer que les produits de consommation
courante le reste il faut se contenter
de le regarder
point 1500 marque 5400 francs pour un
téléviseur couleur pour un simple
appareil noir et blanc 3500 francs un
peu moins de six mois de salaire d'un
ouvrier spécialisé
les dirigeants de berlin-est se donne
encore cinq ans pour soutenir la
comparaison avec l'ouest
ce jour là il n'y aura plus de
frontières